vous avez il avait été le pionnier
d'ailleurs aussi du rove sexe du de tout
de tout parce que vous savez nous a bien
fait vous savez d'où ça vient c'est vrai
elle est fine et la donne est une
question que les gens qui me connaissent
très bien que ça oui les gondoles et
c'est souvent tout sexe il ya 25 ans moi
qui je commençais à pratiquer sa et à
l'époque j'étais très critiquée
aujourd'hui c'est devenu la mode c'est
courant bien sûr c'est une amende je
vais vous dire un truc que vous savez
qu'ici mais qui c'est qui m'a pris un
mois à faire le raf sexe c'était une
copine
j'avais 22 ans je te situes porno que
depuis 12 ans mon la pornographie
c'était beaucoup de femmes devant et
derrière
c'était tout ce que j'avais à faire je
connais c'est autre chose
cette fille la rue n'est pas avoir un
orgasme il m'a mis une claque très fort
dans la figure moi je lui met une claque
mais direct parce que je comprenais pas
réflexe m'a mis une claque c'est
pavlovien je suis tout de suite
ah mais je détiens donc les filles
marchent ainsi façon différente
à partir de là je cherche aussi à
regarder les yeux dans la fir à chaque
fois que je fais l'amour
jamais je les abandonne je sais de les
amener quelqu'un étages différents
un étage qui ne connaissent pas a par
exemple